today we're making Hanukkah crafts and
ruining a perfectly good mason jars
if you don't hate yourself by the end of
the Pinterest it's not a Pinterest yeah
yeah exactly I don't know what I'm doing
actually to be honest you're just paint
popsicle sticks and gluing them together
it's like now reinventing the wheel here
I would totally date a guy completely
covered in metallic paint I'm almost
completely covered in metallic paint Wow
and is today's your lucky day I've never
met a glue gun I didn't hate I should
not be as frustrated as I am right now
no I think you're going ahead of me
because then I can look at you and
decide what I don't want so good and buy
so good I mean I messed it up oh my god
look at yours its beauty or it'll
blinged out that looks beautiful
Thanks mine I don't know they're just
beautiful different sitting next to each
other best friend BFF when I get to the
final step in it find out I glued the
wrong [ __ ] side there's a rage inside
me that I haven't felt in a long time
it's all about lights we're just making
one fancy light this feels like
preschool all over again
it's gonna take my glue pan onions I
want to start with the darkest at the
bottom and then go lighter as you go up
see your crafting I'm so honestly -
somebody brought this to my house and
look what I made you I'd like you need
to take that can you take that home with
you yeah look at this [ __ ] dude I feel
like I was Leonardo da Vinci in another
life
if you got something then you don't
really like it just put a lid plate or
tie on it my plan is you just keep
gluing and keep covering and eventually
I'll die I covered mine with glitter
this isn't my best work I'll say that my
wife would be very proud I think your
wife's be very proud of me yeah just
looking at this one I think this is hard
- [ __ ] that I'm gonna put that out there
in the beginning I'm gonna hope why is
it hard to cut straight lines right now
I'm overlapping my dreidels so that I'm
making one mega dreidel I got three
dimensional this is gonna be a stackable
look at that that looks so hurtful I
wouldn't even try to show this to my mom
actually now that football is leaving
when it needs something to do on Sundays
we have a dog we have stars that's
beautiful that looks really good
don't you lie to me Kurt I swear we'll
look at this this looks like a plain
Jane you're like her sexy hot friend I
really feel like half the stuff we made
you could buy for like a dollar or two
it's not have to make it it's not like
we're making anything that saves you a
lot of money I had a good time hanging
out with curly yeah it was great this
was fun that's what it is right it's a
social aspect of doing crafts we had
quality no Hanukkah making time holidays
are all about bringing family together
and we brought two friends together to
make crafts now L know Happy Hanukkah
Oh Oh